طرق البحريه الامريكيه تتشعب واليوم تسلك
طريقها في بحر جنوب الصين بالقرب من جزر
ستراتلي فالمدمره ميليوس التي تحمل صواريخ
مسيره دخلت بحر الصين الجنوبي توغل وصف
بالاستفزازي وغير القانوني من قبل بكين
التي تواصل مناوراتها حول تايوان لليوم
الثالث والاخير فيما البحريه الامريكيه
تمسكت بقانونيه العمليه التي قامت بها
المدمره يو اس اس ميليس على اعتبار انها
تتوافق مع القانون الدولي وتدعم الحقوق
والحريات والاستخدامات المشروعه للبحر
نيليوس المدمره تشق طريقها في مياه بحر
الصين الجنوبي
واصطحاله ترقب صينيه بسبب توغل السفينه
الامريكيه في مياه الصين الاقليميه فما هي
قدرات هذه السفينه الحربيه
المدمره قادره على القيام بمهام متعدده
لاداء حرب مضاده للطائرات والسفن
والغواصات كل ذلك في وقت واحد كما انها
قادره على اكتشاف الصواريخ الباليستيه
وتتبعها والاشتباك معها
وذلك عن طريق رادار الصفيف المرحلي متعدد
الوظائف
تحمل هذه السفن صواريخ مسيره وصواريخ
هاربون المضاده للسفن
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات